hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the 2018 bill chess festival it's a
shocker Madeira versus Magnus Carlsen
the most awaited game of the tournament
so far as Charlene Mahmoud ro is leading
the tournament by one full point ahead
of Magnus Carlsen
so Carsten would definitely enjoy
winning this game or at least drawing @s
he faces an eco your jihadists in the
final round with the white pieces and
the manager also has to face a Peter
Svidler
where swiller will have the white pieces
in the final round
so before we check out the game we'll
have a couple of photos here a very nice
photo of Mommy divorces cousin it's from
still from the opening both of them just
you know enjoying the position here we
have a nice close-up of Magnus Carlsen
also here a nice close-up of soccer mom
in Europe
and I prepared something I'm sure you
enjoy this is their score so far so
regarding classical games
Magnus cross and beach soccer mum there
are 5 to 1 so 5 wins crossing one winner
off with 11 draws and if you include
rapid and exhibition games and then the
score is 19 2 3 4 Magnus Carlsen with 17
draws so whichever format you check out
classical or rapid exhibition as cousin
is in the lead so also a very nice
opportunity for a shark a MIDI earth as
two I believe two of them are the only
two players that are above 2800 rating
so that being said let's check out this
game and it's also interesting that this
is a game of two world champions and as
Magnus Carlsen is the reigning world
champion Sheffield Madera is the junior
world chess champion as he won the
Junior World Chess Championship but he's
actually the only player ever to win the
Junior World Chess Championship twice
Junior World Chess Championship is below
twenty years of age so let's check it
out I'm your opens with d4 and it's very
interesting I don't know if you remember
the towel versus botanique series our
boat when he could open either wood
Knight f3 or c4 and then when botanique
finally opened with the d4 tal knew that
Botvinnik was up for a fight so could be
the same in this case mamedyarov is
definite
we up for a fight with the white pieces
Knight to f6 c4 the g6 we have the Kings
Indian defense on the board g3 Bishop to
g7 better - G - we have castles Knight
to c3 g6 and now Knight to f3 Crossing
goes c5 and here we have castles Knight
to c6 and III mamita have said in an
intro after the game that he doesn't
really like this III move but you know
yeah it's it's it's not bad here white
can also push the d5 immediately
grabbing the space in the center and
then you could play something like
Knight a5 and Knight e5 Knight back to
b8 I myself enjoy Knight back to to b8
but you know whatever it works for you I
guess so after Knight to c6
we have III my cousin goes d5 now mama
sheriff said that he didn't think that
d5 move was actually you know very good
for black but cousin said that if white
plays III which is a bit more rare that
d5 is actually good for black and that
what it's actually white who struggle if
you want something more other than
equality so Casey capture son d5 Knight
captures Knight captures Queen captures
and the now comes Knight to e5 opening a
discovered attack against Carlson's
Queen we have Queen d6 Knight to c4 now
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 and now
d5 so a very nice expansion by Mahmud
yarv first rook to d8 and developing the
rook as the pawn is now pinned Bishop to
d2 now the point is no longer pinned as
the Queen will not be under attack if
pawn captures and here nice the b4 and
this is a Carlsen showing that he would
enjoy something more than a draw in this
game because if he wanted he could have
gone Knight to e5 and then go for a
series of exchanges tonight captures a
bushel captures every Bishop c3 CalPERS
captures and after b5 it would be a fine
position for both of them with a lot of
pieces you know already traded down so
after Bishop the d2 cross and goes
Knight the b4 and this will create a lot
of complications
Bishop captures pawn capture some before
and now comes Luke the c1 threatening
all sorts of discovered attacks but none
of them actually work for now so a 5
first we have a three pawn captures on a
three point captors on a three and now
comes a for a very nice idea grabbing
more space perhaps preparing the be
three square of for the rook in the
future maybe after the B points traded
down but also locking down White's a
three point on a dark square so it black
will be able to attack it later we have
Queen to d3 and here comes a move that
cousin totally miscalculated
because there are a lot of moves
possible here for example rook b8
preparing to put b5 cousin said in an
interview after the game that rook
twists the rook to a6 is a very
interesting move also if Bishop to d7
then Carlson says that d6 pawn captures
nicely 5 opening up a discard attack
against the Queen but that the black
would be fine here for example if we
check Queen to a5 okay
the the b7 pawn is under attack nobody
can simply capture here capture here and
not even capture on on b7 you can go
Bishop here and the white will have some
nice pressure but black should be able
to hold this a cousin thinks but after
Queen to d3
he played Bishop to f5 he knew that of
course
efore was 84 was coming he brought the
bishop back to d7 which was possible
right away but then he says he totally
missed Queen to e3
Queen to e3 preparing night the b6 and
now this would be a very powerful
discovery as the Queen is guarding the
b6 square and this would open up an
attack towards Carlson's Queen from the
rook and c1 and also attack the a8 rook
so he does have to do something he
played rook to a6
but he already said that he did not
enjoy his position here he 5 by Mahmoud
er of b5 attacking the knight and now
comes d6
so first you know not reacting to the
attack against the night now Carlson's
Queen is under attack and here what do
you do here if you play something like
night the instead of this movie you
could play something like nice the d6
but it doesn't work for example opening
up
discovered attack towards the Queen
about after Queen moves Knight captures
on f7 King captures a six chick captures
captures captures there's nothing for
white here black is perfectly fine here
even up upon so instead after this b5
move like we said there are no good
discoveries this doesn't work
d6 was played here we have Queen to b8
capturing on d6 doesn't really achieve
anything simply helps white D captures
on e7 attacking Carlson's rook so you
still cannot capture knight on d4 our
rook to e8 and now comes Luke F to D one
offering the night here in exchange for
rook captures on d7 Carson doesn't like
this first he captures the pawn back
rook captures on e7 but now comes Queen
to c5 here again my media does not react
to this because now Queen captures on e7
is a possibility and here Crossan played
Queen to f8 this was a miscalculation
but again there's really not all that
much you can play here Queen to d8
doesn't work because okay you protect
the rogue but Queen captures some b5 is
coming the bishop is pinned as the rook
will be attacking the Queen and after
Queen to c5 a move that could have been
played for for you know perhaps is
Bishop to f8 but this is an engine move
very unlikely for a human to play it
because now after Knight to d6 you get
rook captures on e5 this is the whole
point Queen captures rook and now rook
captures on d6 rook captures Bishop
captures and now you will have black
will be up upon but also black will have
a bishop prepare and now if this is
holdable the engine prefers this
position to the one calls and jobs
so after Queen to c5 we have Queen to f8
9 to e3 and this is the move across and
missed when he played Queen to f8 if he
had saw this move perhaps he would
search longer and then perhaps find the
bishop to f8 here 9 3 3 seems impossible
because of course you're constantly
thinking the Knight has to keep an eye
on d5 pawn but actually it doesn't
because now you cannot capture for
example Bishop captures a
you get to rock chapter 77 rock captors
and Queen captures the other problem is
even rook captures on e5 doesn't work
because first you will capture the Queen
there and after Bishop captures rook
captures Bishop to a3 capturing the pawn
and it seems like okay
mm-my a black is down a piece but you
have to connected past points perhaps
you know this this means something but
not really because the variation is for
struck to c8 check King moves rook to c7
attacking the f7 pawn there's really no
good way to defend that only weighs rook
to f6 and now comes Knight to g4
attacking both rooks and now after rook
moves rook e1 we have a bishop to f1
blocking and now after Luke comes to f5
now comes King g2 and pretty much
whatever black plays with the H 593
attacking the rook rook still has to
keep an eye on the f7 pawn Knight to d5
now rook moves and now Bishop to d3 will
win the rook rather the exchange rook
has to move rookie 5 and now rook
captures on f7 ok or either you will
capture the knight or allow better
captures rook if you move the rook then
of course you are getting checkmated
here after rope to rope to f7 this will
be checkmate so not not a simple
position definitely so here after 9 3 3
cross and saw that this was not possible
he played Bishop to e6 we have Queen
captures on b5 grabbing the pawn rook to
a7 and now Knight to d5 Bishop captures
a rope capture Sun d5 and now rook to
eat a b7 Queen to d3 rook comes to b8
not allowing rope to the eight to win
cross since Queen now comes h4
we have Queen to e8 and Queen to d4 now
attacking cousins broken a7
Queen to e7 defending the rook and now
f4 and here cousin plays a door to f8
which is a very nice move if you go for
the a3 pawn which is definitely offered
after Queen captures Queen captures on
a7 Queen captures rook and c1 with check
a king can now move to h2 as h h4 was
played and now you don't really have
anything we drove to b1 and queen to g1
the king will be very safe on h3 and if
you tried the
promising variation rugby - then you get
rook d7 attacking the f7 pawn and after
Queen c2 attacking the bishop on g2 here
comes Queen eight check a butcher blocks
and rook to the 8th the queen is
guarding the bishop here so there are no
threats and there is very little you can
do against this threat so that would be
that would be very nice for white but
you know it's very hard to define such a
move so okay
after f4 we have Bishop to f8 king came
to h2 ever nice move not allowing any
anything you know to happen to the King
while on the first rank-sum discovered
check or something
rook to be 7 by Carlsen and now here
everyone thought that rook the d6 would
be the idea here simply not allowing
Carlsen to threaten Queen captures on a3
and this would definitely keep up the
pressure but he decided to go for Queen
captures on a4 and allowed this exchange
Queen captures on a3 was played Queen
captures on a3 Bishop captures on a3 and
now rook seated e1 we have Bishop to e7
and now comes King to h3 improving the
position of the king
rook to d7 doesn't really do all that
much just yet because the rock simply
captures rook captures and after King to
f8
everything is defended nicely it's very
hard to actually push for something here
it's 4 points against 3 all of the pawns
around the Kings side and the bishops
are of opposite colors so okay after
Bishop to e7 we have King to h3 and now
rook the c7 we have page 5 and here
everyone thought that okay of course you
can capture a pawn here but then your
pawn structure will be completely ruined
no one would do this better yet maybe
simply make a move King f8 or something
but actually cousin simply captures it
here G captures an h5 now the material
and the board is equal but of course
mama D respond structure is much better
here we have f5 calls and pushes f6 he
doesn't want Mahmud arrow to push f6 and
now comes c6 mama Diarra now has an
extremely strong passed pawn here
rook to b3 and here comes rook to d7
you can't go king
for something to go after this pawn
because then you have a GG g g3 pawn
hanging here and of course rook the c-4
will either force you to capture it or
move back so instead we have worked to
d7 and now comes a rook to c3 keeping an
eye on that rook rook to a-1 now comes
King to g7 and now rook to e8 here King
to h6 is played by Carson we have rook
to e8 attacking the bishop and here
Bishop to b4 is played Bishop to b4 a
nice move perhaps after this rock moves
then Bishop to e1 will be possible
pressuring that g3 pawn the rook will
also be pressuring it but also possible
instead aggression before was a bishop
to a3 and now after rook h8 for example
attack engage seven-point cousin could
simply retreat Bishop to e7 but a
similar idea was played in the game
after rook e8 Bishop to b4 was played
and now comes rook to b8 attacking
cousins bishop across and moves the
bishop back and here you could do
something like rook back to e 8 and then
go for the whole rook to h8 idea but
instead Bishop to e4 was played by
Mahmoud Arif we had rook treat the c4
attacking attacking the bishop but also
possible was rook to e3 it's also a very
hard move to find that allows rook
captures on c7 and now Bishop to d6 but
it's also very unlikely that the black
would be able to hold this for example
now rook to g8 defending the g3 pawn has
the bishop and rook are attacking yet
here after you capture the rock now east
7 is coming and now after rook captures
on e4
you get the Queen rook captures rook
captures and now King to g5 and after
rook attacks the bishop and upon Bishop
e5 rook captures on eh7 is coming and
it's very unlikely that black could
actually hold this
but ok after Bishop 3 4 rook 3 to see
for attacking mama dear bishop on e4 we
have rush up to d5 and now comes bishop
to see a rock the c5 attacking the
bishop bishop back to before
rook the c4 and here brush up to d5 and
cross and repeats rook to c5 so if mama
Dara would repeat a bishop to e4 once
again it would be a draw but instead he
goes rooked
seven and now you have to decide what to
do here
capturing on b7 would actually lose you
the game as after Bishop captures your
bat-rope is under attack after we move
at East seven the game is won I you lose
the piece and the game but after up - b7
cousin played the correct move rook
captures on d7 we have rook after some
d7 and here again a very I mean this is
calculating positions like like this is
what chess is all about cousin played
rook to a5 simply if rook captures here
then he will capture back here also
possible was Bishop to f8 and now we
have a very complicated position if you
push each seven black will simply
capture it after rook captures that you
will capture the bishop on d5 but we
have a very exciting moment after Bishop
to a8 displayed now you have to attack
the bishop once again after Bishop to c6
this is the exciting moment because now
it is no longer possible to keep
attacking the LightSquared bishop
because now you can simply push east 7
and after captures white it does not
recapture immediately rather there is an
in-between move at sufficient took
bishop to b7 and after rook moves now
you capture the bishop bishop on e7 and
you are up a piece so after after this
Bishop to c6 you would not be able to
attack it you would have to play Bishop
to a3 and now we would get rook to f7
attacking the f6 pawn rook captures on
f5 e 7 would be played now you would
have to capture it as there would be no
stopping promotion rook captures and now
after rook attacks bishop it would be 3
points against one and if one of these
pawns could ever be sacrificed for this
pawn then a rook and Bishop against the
rook and 2 Kings is a theoretical draw
but it's if you don't know exactly how
to hold it then you perhaps you know a
lot of grandmasters have lost this
position but you know probably Carlsen
wouldn't know how to hold it but ok
after we capture Sun b7 rook to Ava a5
was played with a push up to c6 now you
see that the bishop is on the correct
square it will not be possible to attack
it so now comes a bishop to a3
we have looked to f7 attacking the f6
pawn the threat is of course pushing the
pawn to e7 and here you have to decide
what you want to do if you want to
capture on f5 allow e7 and then after
Bishop captures go into the same
variation as we discussed or play rook
to e5 which is what Crossan played and
now it's very interesting it seems that
now what can freely capture the exponent
but this would not go you know in in
white favour after king g5 the rook is
under attack rook f7 now comes the
Bishop to d6 and it's not all that easy
to push these pawns the rook and Bishop
are guarding it and rook to e3 followed
by rook captures and g3 is coming so
after Bishop d7 rook to e3 King moves
rook captures King moves now comes h4
and now comes the main idea after you
push e7 threatened to promote you have
Bishop to c5 with a forced draw after
the King moves you will either play rook
to e3 and now the King has to move back
to either f1 or f2 of course not f2 but
f1 and if you try to run away with the
king then simply rook captures on e7 and
it's now a draw after rook captures
Bishop captures it's black who has
actually two points but doesn't matter
opposite colored bishops it will be a
draw but here comes a move cousin missed
when he played rook to e5 probably if he
saw this then he would capture here King
to h4 he doesn't allow mom Yara of
doesn't allow cross and to come to g5
would his king and now rook captures
here is definitely a very nice threat
and here cousin says that when he saw
King to h4 that he knew that he
blundered that he was lost and probably
this is the moment where he stopped
thinking but I think someone mentioned
during the live feed that the Norwegian
supercomputer says he said that even
this was not lost that black could
actually still hold this after Bishop to
b4 you know just allowing White's to
make a move still both the bishop and
rook or controlling d7 square even
though the g5 square is not available
for the King now there's still no clear
way to actually push for white here but
as Carson was very unimpressed with
himself you know he could not believe
it after him to that he missed such a
move liking to h4 he played Bishop to c1
and here he thought he didn't think
anything but after mommy tiara played
East 7 ma media of simply start cousin
simply started shaking his head that he
missed such a move and it was in this
position our move 57 that magnus carlsen
resigned the game there are some ideas
okay the bishop is controlling here the
ponies controlling here maybe you could
go for something like rook to e2 to
deliver rook to HT to checkmate
ah but it doesn't work king will simply
go back and after you try something
white was simply bring your Queen into
the game and after Luke captures Bishop
captures white will be completely
winning as there you know after King
captures rook captures it's not the same
as anything we've seen before where
black could actually hold this me down
material so yeah after mushroom trees
after each seven calls and resigned he
blundered with this Bishop to see one
move and although again he thought he
was completely lost here I believe
someone did mention it's in the live
feed that and Norwegian super super
computer says he said that this was
still hold about but ok verse 2 C 1 e 7
and a beautiful beautiful win for
Chicago mom in Europe we have to check
it out one more time there you have it
so the last time this one win in
classical chess mamedyarov achieved
against Magnus Carlsen was in 2008 in
the Chess Olympiad so over 10 years ago
so this is a huge moment for him and a
huge huge victory for him you know
taking down the world champion and there
you have it here here are the standings
no these are not the standings these are
not the correct standings sorry about
that
I'm pretty sure I had him here nope not
that sorry I'm just gonna have to bring
it in okay there we have it sorry about
that okay so there you are so mom in
Europe in clear first place so one run
before the tournament even ended so it
doesn't matter how he plays out his game
against Peter Svidler tomorrow he is
already two points ahead of Magnus
Carlsen and you know he he bait he
Fermo media of 1/2 2018 bill chess
festival Carson is now second with five
ro9 fiddler also in second place would
tie it with caution with 509 then Maxine
was Sheila gravel and half-hour 94.9 and
Nicole gurgi Alice with another draw
with one and a half out of nine so it
will be although the tournament is over
I'm very very interested how Carson's
game against young Nico tomorrow will
will end up because it's a it's a
terrible position to be in
you just lost the game against mama D ro
there are no more chances for you to win
the tournament and tomorrow you could
you know you're you're probably gonna
play a very long game a six hour game
against someone who is more than 300
rating points below you so even if you
draw you will lose lose rating there so
not the greatest position to be in for
Magnus Carlsen but an amazing position
for Sharma media of who who probably
played the best tournament of his life
well he that comes second in the
candidates tournament this year
but you know that's he did not enjoy
that second in the candidates is almost
like last in the candidates but yeah
okay that's the game the video is a bit
longer but you know it's such an end
game it is it's unavoidable I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed
the coverage of the bill chess first of
all so far I would like to thank Silvia
the Carly Colin peek and Anthony
Villalpando for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot - really appreciate
it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video CR think all for watching and I
will see you soon with a video from the
Bobby Fischer series as I could I
couldn't make it to upload a video today
from that series and of course with the
final round of the bill chess festival
so thank you all and I will see you soon